we do have Kelsey with us Kelsey an
absolutely crazy wild game this was we
had no idea what was happening we had
the engine to help us but still couldn't
answer much tell us a bit about your
experience with this game well so in the
opening um when she put the name so she
normally doesn't play after so I
prepared for Quincy too
um and then I played C5 B5 and I wasn't
expecting E5 so here like I was thinking
a lot
um I was thinking the normal for just to
be Retreat to E8 then I was thinking
maybe it would be too passive like
um she might pick up B5 and then develop
normally yeah so I wanted to go for
something like you might as well go for
it right why not let's go for it nothing
to lose Bishop A5 and she was by the way
blitzing out her moves like she knew uh
what she was doing were you afraid of
her collaboration viewers here at this
point but still you're finding the best
moves and take on C4 and at this point
she started thinking a little bit she
had an hour and 33 minutes then F4 was
played after a 10 minute thing how did
you assess the position at this point
also I was really puzzled because I was
thinking there's no way this could work
for her or for me though because like my
pawns they look so ugly but if I can get
a D5 before in yeah um it seems pretty
good for me but she has like no
development so I was really puzzled at
this point yeah no and I think F4 was in
fact quite a big blunder and you jumped
on the opportunity you found the right
plan just get that Rook on the B1 create
those pins and then start pushing the
pawns yeah at this point it became
desperation mode yeah I think like last
Stitch efforts are the most scary
because like they don't have anything to
lose and then I saw she would get a ton
of counter play and then I got really
scared because like I had no time either
you were going down to your last few
minutes at this point
and I think this was the critical moment
you could have played Queen to G6 but
you had one minute on the clock what was
going on through your mind so I was
thinking if I play Queen G6 um that's
what I was originally intending to play
yeah then I was thinking what if my king
gets cut off like somehow quinnish
during the bishop G5 I can always
Retreat to G7 but so I think this was
the move where
um I got down to like 30 seconds yes for
the first time yes and then so I just
had to play a move and then I played
this one which you know 23 seconds and I
have to say you really kept your
composure after this move Bishop to D1
because this is almost like a cold
shower type of situation right
at all like I was either thinking King
D1 or um
something else because here I have
Bishop B5 and Bishop A4 precisely yeah
and this would have led to a victory uh
but she found this great move Bishop to
D1 and then you also counteracted with
this great move to this is from a
practical perspective I think the best
movie in the position
did you see this move Queen to C5
for her or
I didn't consider anything other than
checks because I thought that would be
too slow for some reason yes and that's
what she went for as well and finally
this absolutely Wild game finished in uh
a Perpetual how would you sum up your
experience here at the junior girls
um I guess I shouldn't be disappointed
since it's my first time and
it was too badly
um but I feel like definitely in this
game and all my
um
I lost a lot of games as white which I
wasn't expecting and then this game I
had some good opportunities but
um the tournaments finally almost ending
so yeah Kelsey still you're bringing up
the fighting Spirit to every single game
congratulations and we'll see you
tomorrow in the Final Round Guys any
questions absolutely yeah Kelsey first
of all congratulations what a fighting
game I mean incredible incredible game
we were really enjoying it all those
pawns pushing uh my question is you are
super young you're only 14 years old
national Master really accomplished
chess player uh how are you enjoying
this tournament playing the best girls
like Kare sayib I mean really strong
tournament tournament is this your first
time playing this yeah of course it's my
first time and I always wanted to play
it since a really long time since I just
watched the broadcasts online and then
for this tournament I guess I just want
to play some more good games
um probably good before exciting but
yeah
I just wanted to say thank you Kelsey uh
you thrilled us and you forced the
commentators to put us on our toes so it
was a great game thrilling game thank
you thank you absolutely good luck
tomorrow wow last round love it